iam je suis satisfait que la cour pénale
internationale et s'était saisie
je soutiens la cpi
j'en appelle à la russie pour qu'elles
acceptent de coopérer avec l étoile mais
quand on parle d'un crime de guerre
warcraft il ne faut pas oublier que le
pire des crimes ouah c'est la guerre
elle-même
il soit ils sont et on va en parler avec
vous gauthier rybinski bonjour ce qu'a
déclaré tout à l'heure antonio guterres
est ce c'est important pour l'ukraine
qui justement veut faire reconnaître des
crimes de guerre même un génocide commis
par la russie un ça va encore plus loin
oui mais les paroles du secrétaire
général de l'onu date d'à peu près 50
ans ou 70 ans c'est à dire à l'époque où
il y avait un un pont une liaison entre
l'union soviétique et l'occident parce
que ni l'un ni l'autre ne voulait être
en quelque sorte embarrassé dans leur
développement on n'est pas certain
aujourd'hui que ça soit la même chose du
côté venir poutine donc là ce sont de
bonnes paroles bien sûr mais qui n'ont
aucune chance
d'efficacité dans la mesure où bien sûr
moscou ne veut pas reconnaître sa
culpabilité dans ces massacres qu'il n'y
a aucune raison de penser que même dans
un temps relativement proches ou même à
moyen terme si le pouvoir actuel russe
se maintient et bien qu'il y ait une
volonté de coopérer
le gouffre qui qui de ces par antonio
gouttes âge de moscou c'est précisément
que le langage de goûter h est plutôt
conciliant il a dit lui-même il a dit je
comprends que moscou ait des griefs
moscou n'aurait pas de griefs si la
russie était démocratique desserrant
simplement
donc il a rencontré sa vieille lavrov et
et vladimir poutine mais cette position
conciliante ne fait qu'encourager le
kremlin dans la mesure où dans l'idée de
vladimir poutine l'occident est composé
de lâches
dejean changeant versatile qui ne savent
même pas défendre leurs valeurs et le
secrétaire général de l'onu est
probablement l'illustration de cette
lâcheté